So let me show you how I would go and
predict the 40% of employees who
didn't respond to our survey.
The first thing I would do is I would
take our force model that we're going to
use, and output the model object, so
I'm able to use it in a new workflow.
So I'm going to use an output data tool,
go to File &gt; Browse, and
save this off as Model,
or ModObj_FM for Forest Model.
I can then run this workflow to save off
that model object of the forest model.
Like I had mentioned before,
this is just personal preference for me.
I'm then going to go to a blank
canvas and input that model object,
which I'm going to use in a score tool.
Before I go ahead and bring in a score
tool, though, let me bring in another
data set, which is my 40% of employees
that didn't respond to our survey.
It's titled, Missing Employees,
I'm then going to go to a score tool,
bring that in and
load in each of my input data's
into each side of the score tool.
They're going to bring in
a browse tool and run this model.
What we're able to see now is for every
employee based off this forest model,
what is the predictive probability
that they take either a bike to work,
they drive to work or
they take a public transportation,
bus or train or
whatever it might be to work.
What we should do now is turn this
predictive probabilities into one's and
zeros we can get in actual count.
So how I'm going to do that is I'm
going to build a conditional statement
saying if bike score was greater than
the car and the public transportation
then it should be one and those should
be zeros and vice versa all around, so
we have ones and zeros instead of just
a predictive probability percentage.
With that then I can aggregate my
data up to get the count of how many
individuals should bike, drive or
take public transportation to work.
So let's go ahead and
bring in a formula tool.
I'm going to replace
the square bike field
by building out a conditional statement.
In this conditional statement
is going to be if Score_Bike
is greater than Score_Car and
Score_Bike is greater
than Score_Public Transportation then
we're going to say it's one, else zero.
If I run this, you can seen now we
have square bytes as 1s and 0s,
yet we still have predictive
probabilities for
the score cars and
the score public transportation.
So let's go ahead and do the exact same
thing for now the other two fields.
So if I run this now, what you're
able to see in the browse window,
because we have all 1s and 0s.
So now what we want to do,
is we want to sum up all the records,
or all the values within
each of the score.
Car, the score of public transportation,
and the score of bikes, to then get
the total count of individuals,
who take public transportation,
ride their bike, or drive to work.
So let's bring in
a summarize tool to do this,
where I can simply go over my
score bike, score car, and
score public transportation fields and
add sum.
What that's going to give me is
the sum of the score of the bikes,
sum of the score of the car, sum of
the score of public transportation.
And we can rename those
if we choose to do so.
But what I'm going to do
is simply just hit Run.
Now, what we have here are the results
that we were expecting.
What we have is the mode
of transportation for
each of the 40% of employees that
did not respond to that survey.
So it looks like 913
actually drive to work.
We have 481 that take
public transportation and
141 that bike to work.